speaking of america though and speaking
of black rifle
is it appropriate to play
choco willix savage
instagram there's not many people that
influenced me like him if he was like
hey brenton i need you to get on plane
right now and fly to afghanistan and run
headfirst at some of the taliban guys
yeah you got it yeah i talked to some
people about jocko willock i go did he
see a lot of combat and they were like
they were like oh yeah dude yeah it's
the video chin this one no he's he's a
real warrior look at this guy you ever
had his energy drink watch this no dude
i want
you grow [ __ ] eagle wings good
evening
so hold on pause it pause it let's set
this up this is him he's saying this is
what president biden should have done to
address the nation with the [ __ ] ups in
afghanistan he's like if i was president
this is how i would i watched this last
night he played a troll sleeper
situation in afghanistan
as you know we were set to leave
afghanistan this month and as we began
the final drawdown
i made some critical errors
ownership namely
i underestimated the strength of the
taliban
and i overestimated the strength and
capability of the friendly afghan forces
this was my fault
and due to my mistake
the taliban has taken control of
afghanistan there are reports now that
isis and al qaeda
are working alongside them
unfortunately there are tens of
thousands of americans on the ground
there
as well as friends and allies of america
on the ground
and these people
americans and our allies are all
stranded
and that is my fault
that's right hamlet's at home but they
will not be stranded for long [ __ ]
[ __ ] you guys man in the next 48 hours
we'll be in control of most major
airports in afghanistan
any resistance we meet from the taliban
or otherwise when we seize these
airports will be destroyed completely
and without mercy
from those airports we will conduct
rapid strike rescue missions until we
have recovered and evacuated all our
citizens allies and friends
any person that interferes with these
operations will be killed
we will also
recover or destroy
all aircraft vehicles weapons and
sensitive equipment that we left behind
any person utilizing guarding or located
in close proximity to these weapons or
equipment will be killed
once we have evacuated all friendly
personnel
and recovered or destroyed the weapons
and equipment left behind
we will depart afghanistan
since the last part watch this last part
we will continue to monitor
everything that happens in afghanistan
through our ground and airborne
surveillance equipment
terrorist training camps or activity
will be targeted and destroyed
gross violations of human rights will be
stopped through overwhelming force
and any group in afghanistan
fighting for freedom
liberty
and basic human rights will be supported
through special operations forces
and ruthless precision air power
we will continue that dedicated support
that's how we end it though yeah i've
seen that watch hurry up i don't know 20
seconds just
is no longer a threat to humanity or
to the good people of afghanistan
may god bless america
and may god have mercy on the souls of
our enemy because we will not
but that's how that's how it should go i
want to join the army now right now
you're a young [ __ ] yeah the only the
only problem with wanting to do no
problem no don't criticize no the only
problem with that is that it's it is a
little bit like what we have been doing
so so in other words if you were to say
uh you have to support people fighting
for freedom on that side you are
choosing a side now you have aerial
bombardment now you have special forces
back in there so in a way
it's that that's that's that would be
the that would be the rebuttal right
i'm not trying to hear it from anybody
else
who's going to criticize jocko he's also
been there he's also done missions yeah
he also knows how that works we're
civilians yeah let's take it from that
guy yeah man i have a [ __ ] savage
does he have kids
imagine not your dad yeah that's right
your dad's captain america dude yeah
your dad is [ __ ] the real life
captain america these are rough dudes
that's four kids holy [ __ ] four kids
that's your dad you got a ten year old
dude three daughters and uh the son of
sixteen bro there's so much pressure if
you're history oh my god
you better learn how to fire a [ __ ]
gun you better learn how to kill a man
son who's 16. one hand
what a [ __ ] beast dude
what a beast yeah that's your dad